and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn Anan Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists today we're going to talk
about earning a living we're gonna talk
about being responsible with money we're
talking about choosing a new career path
during these times of financial
uncertainty and man are we really
dealing with some uncertainty right now
and we're gonna do all that with today's
guest our friend Chris Gila beau is back
on the podcast Chris thank you for
joining us today
guys it's such an honor thank you so
much for having me back yeah thanks for
being here man it's awesome to have you
absolutely now before we dive into our
questions from our audience today Chris
you you've written quite a few books a
few of them that include the hundred
dollar startup which may be more more
relevant than ever now also side hustle
and and of course your your podcast
which is is the side hustle podcast and
and I think that also might be more
relevant now than ever but your new book
is called the money tree and I want to
talk to you about that book in a little
bit but I find that your work is really
resonating with people right now because
there is so much uncertainty and it
turns out that maybe this all this
certainty that we've had up till now was
maybe just a misnomer in the first place
that's a good way to look at I think you
know at this point in time people are
questioning all kinds of assumptions
all kinds of assumptions beliefs
principles foundations you know you know
things that we have you know held near
and dear for a long time it's kind of
like you know the world is turned upside
down and so when that happens a lot of
people are scared you know a lot of
people are anxious and worried which is
natural like I've been worried of an
anxious at different times throughout
this process so far but you know when
the world's turned upside down it also
gives you a chance to to make some new
you know assumptions some new principles
some new foundations for whatever it is
that you're trying to do yeah well you
talked a little bit about your your new
book the money tree and how it's
relevant today
yeah you know what's so interesting is
people are saying it's relevant I'm like
well I wrote it you know like a year ago
I had no idea obviously and it's also a
strange time to launch a book you know
in some ways it's it's terrible in some
ways it's the best time you know but you
know leaving that aside you know the
book is about finding the fortune in
your own backyard and it's a story it's
a narrative I'm trying to teach
something still like I do in my other
books but I'm trying to use a story
that's relatable that's that's
entertaining and inspiring and it's
essentially about you know a young young
guy who has a good job and he also has a
lot of student loan debt like so many
people do and he's basing all this
financial pressure that then affects the
rest of his life his relationship his
day job everything else and he's just
trying to find his way out so he's
trying to find different options and you
know people make suggestions and they
say he should just work harder they say
he should you know drive for a rideshare
or whatever and obviously those things
aren't the you know the ultimate
solution so he has to find something
else he ends up going to a group of
people that are all trying to you know
either get out of financial pressure or
you know even if they're not facing
immediate financial pressure to create
something you know better for themselves
in the future to create their own new
way of life like you guys talked about a
lot and so he basically like navigates
that process so it's essentially like
the hero's journey applied to you know
somebody trying to create a new future
for themselves create that financial
economic security yeah well I definitely
wanna dive into some questions we have
from our audience because Chris I think
you're really good at helping people out
so let's try to help some people out
today our first question is from Tony in
Phoenix Arizona I work a great company
where I'm well and treated well but I
feel like my life is Groundhog Day
I feel really trapped working in an
office and I feel like I'm wasting my
life sitting in a desk with only a few
three hours a day to really live and
ultimately I don't want to work for
someone else and I don't want to have a
traditional office job but I feel really
stuck and I don't know how to figure out
an alternative they don't have any debts
or a monthly car payment I just feel
really ready for a big change as far as
my work but I don't know what to do or
how to figure it out so I was just
wondering what advice you might have as
the
I can figure out what my next step is
all right Chris I feel like you are the
master of helping people kind of get
that inspiration to leave their job and
to do something they they really really
like what what would your advice be for
Tony yeah I mean that's quite a setup
but thank you huh Tony thanks that great
question I think Tony's in an
interesting position because you know
she's in that job that she describes as
being a pretty good job you know and
she's treated well so that's great but a
lot of people are realizing now you know
whether whether it's a good job or not
not a good job like security in the long
term does not come from a job security
in the long term doesn't come from a
corporation it doesn't come from the
government from an organization you know
again even a good company organization
or government so you know she's really
wise there and saying you know I want to
do something else second thing is like I
think it's it's so much harder to leave
a job that's decent or as good or it's
just like okay than it is to leave one
in which you're miserable you know like
some ways misery is a much better
companion than mediocrity right because
if you're miserable you're like I gotta
get out of this situation like I gotta I
gotta change but if it's like okay you
know it's like decent well I should be
four I should feel you know fortunate
because I have a job I've got my health
insurance you know etc it's really hard
for people to make changes in that place
and so it's great that she's actually
like being proactive and it's not you
know the stuff I want to actually you
know make a change like I am
dissatisfied I am discontented and it's
so important I believe to pay attention
to that like to pay attention to that
feeling of you know something about this
isn't right for me it doesn't matter if
it's right for somebody else it doesn't
matter that it's a good job you know if
you know other people are struggling I
can still struggle in different ways
like your struggles are not you know
comparative to others so the discontent
is there that you know the desire is
there I think the next thing is okay so
what are we gonna do and at that point I
think a lot of people are focused on
this dichotomy of like I'm gonna leave
my job and start this other thing and I
always suggest or almost always you know
why do you have to you know leave your
job to start the other thing why don't
you start the other thing right now you
know why don't you start the other thing
whatever situation your and even if you
have limited time like we all have
limited time and people make time for
what's important to them so in some ways
being busy is like this benefit actually
more than a handicap like if you've got
limited time you know Tony it's been
spend one hour
you know a day trying to figure out okay
what is my next thing am I gonna start a
business and we're gonna start if it's a
business what kind of business is it is
it a product it just is it a service you
know is it some kind of reselling thing
or like whatever it is what's the next
step for that and then I think from
there we could talk you know on and on
about like all the different steps of
like identifying the idea and how to
implement the idea and such but I think
that's the path basically the path is to
say you know today basically rather than
think like four weeks in advance or four
months in advance when you leave the job
or whatever period it is what am I going
to do today to get closer to that goal
of eventually you know finding more of
my path so to speak yeah you know we
often we often think about like just if
we're discontented with one area running
into our boss's office and yelling screw
you I quit and well I suppose maybe
there's a place for that somewhere but
but that's not how reality works and I
like the practicality of your advice
Chris not not just what you you've
talked to Tony about but what you've
written about and what you've podcasted
about where it's not as cut and dry as
simply walking away from or running away
from your current job it's having
something to walk toward yeah and
although I think sometimes we confuse
excitement for passion so maybe you can
talk about as tony is sorting through
these ideas of what she wants to do next
and finding what she wants to do next
what are some ways to identify that yeah
just thinking about that first thing you
said in terms of you know walking to you
walking into your boss's office and
saying screw you I think there is a
place for it I mean I think you said
that well of like you know there's a
time in a place for it and I think you
always have to ask like what are the
stakes like what is at stake here and if
you are you know 20 years old or
whatever it is you're in an entry-level
job you don't have a ton of
responsibilities you know and your job
sucks then then why not just quit you
know you might as well quit because you
can you probably find something better
and you know in the worst case scenario
you're not
gonna be that much that much worse off
but obviously like you know you guys
have a lot of listeners who are older
with families and mortgages and you know
just the the burdens of life and all
that kind of stuff and part of the
reason why they're attracted to this
movement is they they want to live more
simply but it's a process you know it's
gonna it's a path so how do you then go
from I think you put it like the
separation of like excitement and
passion and I I would just add a couple
words there you know skill and value and
so value as I think of it it's you know
it's this business word that's thrown
around all the time but I think about a
value was just helping people you know
what what you guys do with the podcast
and everything else it's it's valuable
it's helping people so you know Tony or
anybody else what can you do that helps
people what is and then what is your
skill more than what is your passion
what is your skill you know let's make a
list of all the things that you are good
at I think that's a much more effective
path and let's make a list of all the
things you like to do it doesn't mean
you're going to end up doing something
that you hate I mean normally what
you're good at we're also kind of
passionate about there is a connection
there but by focusing more on that like
what's going to be helpful to somebody
else it's just a much better business
path to go down than like okay I like
ice cream you know how can I make money
you know eating ice cream or something
there's probably some path to do that
but it might be easier to do like what
am I actually really good at you know
what's fascinating about that Chris is
quite often when you think about
businesses you think that they're
selling products or services but
ultimately what they're doing is they're
helping people solve problems every
successful business no matter whether
they're a fortune 500 company or a
mom-and-pop shop on your street they are
helping solve some sort of problem for
their customers and if you can help
people do that ultimately if you're
adding enough value to those people's
lives the money does tend to show up
mm-hmm
yeah you know I think I think sometimes
like the mistake people will make it and
you said it Chris like though they'll
say what can I do that's going to what
do I like and how is it going to make me
money and instead of tagging that last
part on how it's gonna make me money
just start with what do I like and how
can I help people the other thing too is
I feel like another mistake people make
and I did
this cuz I was totally in Tony's
situation and you know I can empathize
where she was I was at a point where I
was working 60 70 80 hours a week I was
in Groundhog Day and for me it wasn't
about I didn't start to think oh what
can I do that I'm passionate about what
I started to think was is how can i how
can I get to a point where I can leave
my job and do something that will give
me my time back because ultimately
that's what I wanted I wanted more time
during the week to do the things that I
love to cultivate passions because at
the time I didn't necessarily know what
I was passionate about and I think
sometimes people they look at that new
job as something that's this ultimate
one answer and they could do this for
the rest of their lives and they're
never going to hate their job again
but unfortunately the human condition is
once we get used to something once we
master something we always want to move
on to something else so you know I would
I would give Tony a little advice and
tell me if you agree with this Chris I
would say hey you know figure out what
you want out of your job and and and
figure out you know what you want to do
outside of your job and and then maybe
you can move towards that like for me I
thought to myself okay I want my time
back so how am I gonna do that well a
I've got to pay off some debt so that
was stuff number one for me start paying
off debt and then why my ultimate goal
in Josh's goal is we were gonna you know
go be baristas and eventually open up a
coffee shop and it wasn't like we loved
making coffee but we we had an interest
in coffee and we really you know we a
bit of a connoisseur of coffee but
ultimately it was being a barista to
work 30 maybe 40 hours a week but having
that time after my job to do things that
I love I didn't rely on that you know I
wasn't thinking that barista job was
gonna be this magic bullet answer for ya
it was something that would give me my
time back you were passionate about
getting your time back which is yes
pretty pretty powerful motivator and
it's funny you mention the coffee thing
because you know when I started doing my
stuff like 20 years ago you know working
for myself I started by selling on eBay
you know it literally was 21 years ago
and you know eBay had just come out and
I
selling stuff and it was so exciting
because I wasn't passionate about like
I'd started by selling stuff around my
house and then like you run out of stuff
around your house to sell and you start
looking to see what else is selling and
then okay I can buy lego at this price
or I can buy actually coffee as well I
so I imported coffee for awhile from
Jamaica and resold it and I wasn't
passionate about any of those items at
all i get it i think i did cigars for a
while i just like fashion and women's
purses just all kind of just random
stuff basically and not passionate about
a single item or category but yet you
know the act of like learning to to
create this you know economic i dont
influx it was like I'm getting paypal
notifications like from people I don't
know on the internet like sending money
to like buy stuff it was so cool I was
like this is great I have no idea what
I'm doing and I'm making you know twice
as much money was like fifteen dollars
an hour in the last job I had was eight
dollars an hour and you know this is
very motivating like if I learn more
about this I can probably do even better
and maybe eventually I will specialize
and you know later on I get you know
better at something more specific and I
don't want to sell Lego and coffee for
the rest of my life but when I was doing
it it was pretty fun you know I was
surprised at how passionate I felt about
something that I had never thought about
before just because it was this new
thing and it was bringing me that
freedom so very similar to you Ryan Tony
I'm going to send you a copy of Chris's
new book the money tree I think you'll
find a lot of value in that and I want
to just wish you good luck and your
search for your new path Kristin in Los
Angeles has a question for us after some
serious soul-searching and hard-ass work
throughout my 20s I'm rounding the
corner to 30 and feel at a real loss of
direction I pursued and finished a
specialized degree and penetrated the
field very quickly and really grew
professionally within the last six years
I also made some Bank money during that
time and paid off my student loans and
yet at 29 I realized this is not what I
want to do anymore I find myself almost
back to the start since my degree is so
specialized and even entry-level
positions in other industries won't look
at me because I'm air-quote
overqualified
uh do I go back to school I'm sorry this
whole process over I'm an intelligent
human so I know I can do really anything
I was so confident ten years ago and yet
I feel unsure about what's next
especially when it involves debt yet
again well Kristen I unfortunately have
some bad news for you if you haven't
discovered your passion by age 29 then
you're never going to find it no I mean
Chris this is fascinating the few things
that stood out here like she doesn't
want to go into debt totally agree with
that
I I don't do debt we discourage people
from doing debt in general in fact I
think that's one of your principles with
respect to you know doing the $100
startup when someone comes to you says I
only have 20 thousand dollars to start a
business you will say well it sounds
like you have too much money to start
your business that's right but but with
Kristin she was so confident before but
now she's not feeling that same sense of
confidence and I think that's directly
correlated to how she feels about the
the current working environment so
here's what I think Kristin you know
what got you here won't take you there
basically like Kristin obviously is
really smart she's hardworking she
worked her ass off I think she said you
know saved money you know got that
specialized degree you know so obviously
all these qualifications where you want
to go next you need a different skill
sets and you don't acquire that skill
set by going back to school so I'm not a
big fan of telling people like what to
do you know obviously if you if that is
the best path for you then you go and do
that but just based on what what I heard
there you know you've already followed
that path basically you follow that path
you know how to excel in that kind of
environment etc and when you say I think
she said something about how like I feel
like I'm starting over I don't I just I
just disagree with that respectfully
because you know at age 29 she's had a
lot of experiences sounds very similar
to me in some ways you know similar but
different because at age 29 is when I
started thinking about what do I want to
actually do with my life because I had
done a bunch of different stuff and it
all felt kind of random like I liked all
the stuff I had done I was an aid worker
for several years I had you know been
that eBay entrepreneur I had started
traveling to a bunch of places
but there was really no connection
between those things and I was
dissatisfied and out of that experience
is how I ended up starting a blog the
art of nonconformity and a lot of other
stuff that came came later so I don't I
don't think she's gonna start over I
think it's what is the collection of
this stuff that she has learned they had
the experiences the knowledge and the
answer is probably not like so just as
it's probably not going back to school
it's also not you know the entry-level
position in some other industry because
you know she is overqualified for that
the question is what is she qualified to
do and it may not be an easy answer in
the sense like this is the job on you
know LinkedIn that you were supposed to
go and apply for right now it probably
isn't actually it probably is something
that's a totally different direction
she's talking about like she's feeling
dissatisfied or whatever words you know
she used so I probably is something
that's completely different and I don't
know what that is but I think you know
what what got you here won't take you
there so therefore this is the time to
actually rethink maybe everything
perhaps yes I love that you said that
man so Kristen isn't just starting over
she's starting over with experience
which is a huge perspective shift and
Kristen like you absolutely have to
appreciate that
I do have one piece of advice on
figuring out kind of what maybe Krista
wants to do next I know I did this when
I was in the corporate world I started
just kind of daydreaming on jobs that I
thought would be interesting and I
remember one specific job was the CEO of
the Better Business Bureau and so I
emailed the CEO of the Better Business
Bureau in Dayton Ohio and I said hey I'm
interested in what you do can I take you
out and have a you know buy you a cup of
coffee or buy you some lunch and maybe
we can talk about you know what your job
looks like and he was totally amicable
to do that and I did that with a couple
other people and some people said yes
some people didn't respond to me which
is fine but I really loved that approach
I don't regret that approach of going to
different people whose jobs I was kind
of interested in and just taking them
out for a cup of coffee and seeing what
their job was like and see if it was
something I wanted to pursue further you
know Ryan people often think that
because at age 29 is when we started the
minimalist yeah a decade ago right and
people often think well you guys start
it over and you walked away but Chris
brings up such a good point that
we really carried all the knowledge and
the skills that we had developed over
the course of the the 12 years working
at that corporation that we worked with
in fact we were still working at the
corporation this is Chris's advice as
well it's not like we just left there
and started a blog we we started the
minimalists comm back in 2010 a decade
ago and we were still in the corporate
world for quite a while afterward and
and still paying down dead and so it was
a more slow transition but also all
those skills whether it was public
speaking or presenting or business
writing or managing people leading
people these are all skills that carried
forward to ultimately what we do right
now and we had established this nice
foundation that this isn't a completely
different thing from what we were doing
before even though ostensibly
it might appear to be nothing like
managing a bunch of retail stores there
are certainly some skills that move
forward mm-hmm
yeah the soft skills always carry
forward I think that's the thing to when
Kristen was talking about her skills
she's probably thinking about the hard
skill like this is I learned you know
chemistry or Electrical Engineering or
whatever but the the skills that
everything that Joshua just mentioned
and also like she talked about working
her ass off well I have a feeling that a
lot of people listen to this podcast or
watch the video our overachievers which
which is great but a lot of the
population doesn't know how to work
their ass off a lot of population
doesn't know how to manage like life and
work without getting into a lot of debt
and feeling overwhelmed so she's got a
lot of skills I'm sure I think those are
the skills that that are highly valuable
more than just like what you're you know
bachelor's degree or your master's
degree or whatever is in yes Kristen
I'd love to send you a couple tickets to
our less coast tour stop we just had to
reschedule this entire tour because
we're currently on quarantine Chris
you're supposed to be out this this
month in April doing a West Coast tour
of the United States and Canada and
we've moved that back to November so
anyone who got tickets those are
obviously going to transfer over you
don't have to worry about that but
Kristen I'd love to invite you to this
event we're gonna have a special guest
there we'll do a live version of the
podcast we'll give a talk about
minimalism people will be asking
questions we'll be
answering those questions you can come
on out we even have a special musical
guest for folks at home who are
interested it's just the minimalists
comm a slash tour for tickets Ryan what
time is it you know what time that is it
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer your text messages you can
text your questions and comments to nine
three seven two zero two four six five
four yes indeed those texts go to both
of our phones Ryan's and my phone and we
don't answer every question although
we're quarantined right now so we're
answering almost every single and we do
reply to as many as we can during
lightning round this was where Ryan and
I and our guest we attempt to answer
questions with just a short shareable
less than 140 character response and we
put the text to these minimal Maxim's in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our pithy answers on social media if
you'd like and now you can find all of
our minimal Maxim's in one place minimal
maxims comm we got our first question is
from cullen what is the best advice
you've ever gotten regarding money Kris
have you gotten you don't have to give
us a pithy answer although if you have
something tweetable great we could we
can Mandar all in a bit though and and
we'll tweeze out something beautiful
these texts don't come to my phone so I
wasn't prepared yeah that's right God
except I actually I'm not sure I've
received a lot of advice about money you
know I was trying what is the best or
the worst I don't I don't really know
that I was ever taught about money you
know for better or worse um it's
something that's not the major failings
of our school systems it seems like
we're where we teach geography and in
history and and and certainly important
subjects but we we tend to skip over
some of the fundamentals of adult life
and one of those is how to manage money
well my pithy answer is there's no such
thing as good debt and for me that
advice I wish I would have been given
that I wish would have been seared into
my brain at age 18 because at 18 I got
my first credit card and from there I
had like over ten credit cards in my
wallet and and I was racking up debt
making really good money spending even
better money living paycheck to paycheck
and really creating a lifestyle that
wasn't only sustainable but it wasn't
enjoyable either it was I was tethered
to it because just because of that debt
and so if you can avoid debt do whatever
you can to avoid it that's that's really
what I would say I totally agree with
that Josh now I know some people
listening to this they might email us or
tweet us something but there's this one
situation where you can leverage debt
and yet maybe maybe for someone like
Mark Zuckerberg who can instead of
paying eight million dollars upfront for
a house he can take that 8 million
dollars and invest it into the stock
market I mean there are exceptions to
the rule but I can tell you that
personally I've never had debt that I
was grateful that I had ever my pithy
answer is this though well first off
Josh I think your advice I think that is
the best advice but you know I guess the
second best advice that comes to mind is
it's never too late to start saving for
retirement now I started saving for
retirement regularly when I was probably
29 30 years old so I wasn't too old but
that advice I want to transfer that to
anyone you know who a 50 year old 60
year old 7 year old who's listening to
this and they haven't started saving for
debt the the lie that I think people get
wrapped up in is this oh it's too late
for me to save up for retirement and
it's not going to it's it's not gonna be
enough by the time I get there but
that's just not true
you can absolutely start saving any time
the worst thing you can do is is not
save Chris do you have any any money
advice maybe you haven't gotten a bunch
of advice regarding money but you
certainly must have some earning money
is more important than saving money
that's my advice
explain it's great yeah yeah I feel like
so a lot of people are you know into the
this you know idea of like trying to say
for early retirement that's a very
popular trend now and and I think it's
good because that's also I could you
know a debt-free kind of principle like
debt is bad like I agree and there's
there's two fundamental like approaches
there it's like one is like you you save
as much as you possibly can some people
are like I'm saving 80% of my salary and
you know living on a thousand dollars a
month and and that's I think that's
admirable but you know the the way that
you're really going to like get a
and build wealth if that is your goal or
just think about security or you know to
be able to achieve more whatever it is
you're trying to actually do you know if
you just have an average salary it's
kind of a long road you know like yes
it's true that like you know compound
interest investing over time you know a
hundred years from now you know a dollar
will be whatever and you're gonna be you
know hit by a bus you know the year
before you retire etc etc but the best
thing you can do is really increase your
income because if you increase your
income and you can save more but it's a
lower percentage you know again it with
an average salary it's going to be very
difficult to if you have see if you have
significant debt let's say which a lot
of people do you know like I'm I'm
totally on board without no debt
philosophy but I also just recognize
that a lot of people kind of come to
this perspective because of you know
decisions that they made earlier and so
the way you're gonna sort that problem
out is not by cutting out your your
coffee you know or whatever the example
is though I'm gonna you know save $30 a
month you know well what if you made
$300 more a month because of a
relatively simple thing that you did why
don't you do that does it require
walking away from your your current
career what you're talking about what
you talked about with your with your
podcast is you can develop some sort of
side hustle a side business do
additional revenue streams in your own
life that that are going to help you so
you're not worried about oh should I buy
lunch or coffee to this right exactly I
feel like these are these are choices
that kind of way people down they become
burdensome and then they start feeling
really bad about you know spending small
amounts of money like a small amount of
money can often make your life better
and in a you know pretty meaningful way
whether it is that coffee or something
else and I don't want people to just
feel like they have a every time they
are spending money then it's like this
negative thing you know we have to like
trade money for something other stuff
that we need to live and so the best
thing you can do is to earn more money
alright before we get into our added
value segment and our listener tips
today it looks like we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week yes indeed
what can these uncertain times tell us
about minimalism everyone's talking
about money IQ but what about money
EQ what's the your emotional
intelligence around money especially at
a time like this
also what's your 401k and
entire Minh savings strategy and advice
during these times and how do you start
your side hustle with hope in an
environment of fear Plus how do I break
ties with the job to which I feel an
emotional attachment plus we got a bunch
more questions for Chris and if you want
to hear all that listen to this week's
maximal episode on the minimalist
private podcast that's right you're
currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
and our guests record an entirely
different much longer maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast let me
just say this this is a bonus episode it
is a much longer episode it's an
entirely separate endeavor and it is
just two bucks and it is the most honest
way for this podcast to earn an income
because we don't believe in
advertisements we think advertisements
suck so we make money only if you find
value in and support what we create by
the way when you subscribe to the
minimalist private podcast you'll
receive a personal link so that our
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app you find all the details
over at the minimalists com slash
support Ryan what else you got for us
here are some voicemail comments in tips
from our listeners check them out hey
Joshua and Ryan this is Louis from well
in the UK I have a tip related to two
hundred and twenty ninth podcast tech
problems
the majority of us when we receive a
smart phone never changed the default
sounds played for notifications received
so when we hear one of these default
sounds this can create an unnecessary
urge for us to pull out our smart phones
and only to find the notification was
received on another nearby device by
changing the default sounds on your
smart phone to sounds you don't hear
within your home and working environment
over time you learn to disassociate
these sounds with your smart phone I
found this helps maintain my focus in
busy environments and has reduced
unnecessary checking of my own smart
phone
hey Josh and Ryan this is Haley from
Arkansas I feel like I've noticed a lot
of other parents that are trying to get
into this minimalism thing having
trouble knowing what to do with all of
the crafts and drawings and things that
their children bring home from school
and I recently discovered an app called
keeping that's ke e py and it's really
neat you can take a picture of whatever
the item is and you can write a
description of it you can put when it
was created and where and then you can
also record a video of your child
describing what the drawing is of and
you can separate it to all your children
so you have a different folder for each
child and then you can share all these
things privately with whatever family
and friends that you want to the app it
costs about $15 a year but that seems
really reasonable to me to cut down on
the stuff that you're saving and then
there's another app or a website called
keepsake and that so does a queue so
it's qu e EP s a ke and it's a service
to help with recording memories of your
kids kind of in a place of a baby book
if you wanted and you can go in and
enter your child's information and then
they will text you questions as
frequently as you want to pay for the
free services once a week but you can
have it every day for each child if you
want to and also text pictures if you
want to
so they text you a question and you
reply back and then they save it and
then you can just log in and look at
your book if you want you can
print it out if you desire to at some
point but that's another way that
parents can cut down on some of the
clutter that comes with the fun parts of
parenting alright Joe thanks again to
Chris Gila beau for joining us today you
could check out his new book it is
called the money tree you can also check
out his podcast it is called side hustle
school we'll put a link to both of those
in the show notes and real quick four
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalists well obviously as you can
see if you're watching the video version
of this we are quarantined in our homes
but we're doing something called
quarantine conversations over on patreon
right now we're calling up some friends
and also friends of the podcast and
getting their take on how they're not
just thriving or not just surviving
these times but maybe there's a way to
to thrive amidst all of the anxiety and
fear and discontent and and worry of
these current times we can get past that
in fact my daughter and I just did a
video on patreon right now called the
five stages of quarantine we talked
about the five stages of grief I think
maybe the sixth stage is thriving
getting past the grief altogether of all
of this and figuring out a way to thrive
in these strange unfortunate
circumstances so Ryan and I are gonna
call up some friends get their unique
perspective just different friends from
all different walks of life people we've
known for a long time maybe since
childhood people we've just met in the
last few years and trying to get their
unique perspective on how they are
handling and how they're coping with the
the the momentary quarantine you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimalists
if you have a comment question or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
comm comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our e-mail list over at the
minimalists comm you can also receive
our simple Sunday emails each week over
there and for our added value this week
Ryan have you listened to the weekends
new album oh no I have it man
I need to check it out I didn't realize
he yeah it just came out and like
I don't know if this is a great time to
release an album or maybe it's like the
perfect time I'm not sure his music is
kind of I think of his music as like
driving around at night music what you
can still do I guess well while we're
quarantined driving around alone but uh
what a perfect song title here his new
album is called after hours by the way
and this the song is called escape from
LA and I know there are some people were
doing that during the the pandemic and
so go ahead you know I will say that
this is the time probably to create
music for sure I don't know if it's the
best time to put an album out but if
you're sitting at home and your musician
write some music yes yes indeed well
here's the weekend his song escape from
LA from the new album after hours and if
you leave here today with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listen y'all
we'll see you next time and minimus